ciao uil ultimo appuntamento con un
ragazzo conosciuto in palestra c'è da
fuori che arriviamo al ristorante tutto
bene ho portato il conto lo riguarda e
fa beta e si sa il primo appuntamento
pagano le donne ma le donne come fanno a
rimanere etero davanti a queste cose che
vi devo invece comunque capo giustifichi
che abbiamo fatto la nostra vera
appuntamento ha offerto una birra un
appuntamento è quindi tu mi ha offerto
una vera e propria auto a metano che
falso io i rigori che tu pensavi che
tipo che mangiarsi troppo poco troppo
poco periodo che ci sono frequentati
migliori posizioni presso le sfondi da
qualunque valso adesso quella museruola
ciao a tutti ben tornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata qui sul mio
canale il tema della puntata di oggi è
primi appuntamenti per un tema così
delicato ho pensato di invitare
all'interno degli studios dei casa mia
un ospite è particolarmente atteso
nonchè richiesto all'interno del mio
canale una persona con la quale ho
effettivamente avuto un primo
appuntamento il mio ragazzo luigi capra
stesso l'attento non muovere la
impercettibile guerra si doterà
scoprirlo io ero sicuro salvo uno degli
appuntamenti che ha avuto è stato
abbastanza traumatico in quanto fu quasi
al buio in un accordo tramite chat e
l'under grinder passeggiata tranquilla
quando ad un certo punto ti stai fermo
qui c'era però sulla ringhiera parapetto
con le spalle rivolte verso il mare
sembra se pantaloni e incominciate le
aree davanti al mio polino senti eviti
praticamente tutto come ti viene in
mente che aveva mantenuto con fi
ma soprattutto mi indichi dove rimanere
questa è qui per molti può goditi la
scena
ti racconto di questo primo appuntamento
ormai risalente a diversi anni fa
in realtà è sbagliato definirlo primo
appuntamento nel senso che lui non si è
presentato quindi mi sono beccata una
buca clamorosa ma solo il giorno dopo ho
scoperto che non si è presentato perché
era stato arrestato
la prima ragazza quindi primo
appuntamento in assoluto
lei era fatta di hashish di come vincere
maini non fatela vedremo un po distante
da sera ma che pensavo della saperci
fare
era lei beve rai il primo appuntamento è
pari a ci vada meriggio è perché
inseguendo invece brasile non ci sono
mai capitate cose strane forse una volta
che devo solo questo ragazzino che
rendono durante il tragitto
eravamo in in autobus ma non abbiamo
visionato come mi dispiace per questo
ragazzo
buongiorno vi scrivo ragazzo grinder
sembrano molto carino e molto raffinato
dalle foto in realtà ci conosciamo ed
era tutt'altro che ha cominciato a
lottare al tavolo a urlare contro il
cameriere volevo sprofondare fino a
quando un certo punto mi chiede se
volessi sentire la presenza o inventato
una scusa tipo che un problema di
diarrea e sono scappato un abbraccio
tipo mai di un presenti la presenza che
aleggia in questo ristorante
certo la pizzo prima cui il logo e
medium riguardo anch'io punti ce n'è uno
in particolare
ciao riguarda i primi appuntamenti ce
n'è uno in particolare che te devo
raccontarti perché vede eravamo a casa
di una mia amica e abbiamo conosciuto
conosciuto un ragazzo della sua
compagnia
veramente la stessa sera ci siamo un po
tipo sbaciucchiati sul divano coseno
miss e creato addosso ea un certo punto
mi ha chiesto la senti la bestia questa
roba incantatrice impersonare l'oboe
media talpe pronta per la tana tour eno
appuntamenti in avuti pochi ma quello
che mi ricorderò per sempre stato quello
con questo ragazzo io ho avuto la
malsana idea di farlo andare a mangiare
del kebabaro sta di fatto che ci fa
messo anche dei bambini morti dentro
questo che vadano barche l'alito arriva
a noleggio del bacino quindi un mezzo
limone minimo na i vinti i denti c'è già
l'alito faceva cagare il caso la pulizia
dei denti sanno fare i coccodrilli degli
uccellini
no no no no come succede con i denti
che schifo adesso primo di muro di lui
solo rimanente esa come la sua prima
esperienza mora pronto mamma
buongiorno quel giorno non ho letto a
posto a posto ci pensiamo noi tranquilla
ok anche me va bene
mi fa piacere se al pareggio
e io non esisto sono bambino avevo 14
anni era ogni spiaggia e moduli per
baciarla ma dove darebbe c stampa e gli
spalanca la bocca per il 3 come se mi
stesse mangiando e io ho detto bambole
limonare ben venga la mia lingua frutto
nella sua bocca non trovando niente
nessuna lingua tutto morto e les pretres
spalancato la bocca della ferma non so
fare è nativo respirazione bocca a bocca
ei 14 anni ne abbiamo dovuto predisporre
una bara dove era così esatto parlaci
dente no ma è un modo diverso
[Musica]
sento prima questo ragazzo per circa un
mesetto decidevo di vederci la faccio
breve
l'orrore mi rimarrà sempre rimasta dalla
stampa di strutture che li ha per va in
acqua in casa macchina a me non è mai
capitato
spero produzione ricordate il bomber
battuta cattiva soprattutto adesso che
le fatta ti senti meglio con te stesso
adesso che si segue aspetta di primi
appuntamenti come vedono appuntamento in
questo tizio e mi ricordo ancora sua
frase che è stato io sono stando almeno
mille pound al giorno in un 100 sento un
poveraccio guardato io devo andare in
bagno ho chiamato i miei amici e gli ho
detto vi prego voi sarà 10,02 mi
chiamate incominciato a parlare in
italiano tanto questo qui è tedesco non
capisce un cazzo e mi iniziata a
raccontare che ne so in maniera
concitata e piccoli porcellin siamo tre
fratellini ce n'è un altro ancora
scusami cos'erano degli appuntamenti di
quelli veloci spiegel
sono stato dieci giorni non ho visto 20
briscoe il primo appuntamento al cinema
e oltre a essere dovuto andarla a
prendere che va beh ci sta ma eravamo
nella sala a vedere il film è una scelta
mi arriva un messaggio di lui che
assoluto di fianco mai mi dice ma come
faccio a sapere se ti piaccio etico l'ho
guardato il telefono tipo ok è descritto
può non so che la pace e lui mi manda un
altro messaggio e lo scrive bacia
ma che cazzo di problemi ai ceo una
ragazza dice beh non lo so prova c è un
po come dirty sì esattamente
mi piace questo reggono provaci e tu
cipro vincendo baciarmi fidanzati ma che
poi dice ho avuto erano tutti ex di una
mia amica con cui lei si era lasciata in
rete
quindi che punta mi chiedo sempre perché
questo ambito voleva esserci a tutti i
costi calcolando che la nemica soffre di
attacchi di panico ci siamo ritrovati
più volte a soccorrere perché spegne va
o pescata un i parchi o parlando con
questo ragazzo che a un certo punto è
svenuta
lui che cercano comunque di di trovare
una soluzione di sistemarla dio
brillante arrivato in sinni ma è che ci
ha dato una mano tra l'altro la mia
migliore amica
l'appuntamento con noi perché stavo
rella sviene in continuazione ma lascia
elise venute scappa o buone né terra via
mare semisconosciuto pescara lei una mia
amica la settimana scorsa è uscita con
un ragazzo per la prima volta in realtà
sono solo questi per una sigaretta e il
tizio le fa ma ti dispiace se mentre i
fumi o facile bolle e tira fuori dalla
tasca una boccetta di sapone mentre la
marca fumava lui ha fatto poi
legislatore possa dire una cosa
[Musica]
una cosa bellissima
ok non è proprio vuoi fumare il mio
cubano capito cioè ti dispiace se mente
su fondi faccio il bowl super romantico
però il nostro primo appuntamento è
avvenuto cinque anni di governo però 4 e
voglio dire una cosa
appena ci siamo salutati to me subito
dato un bacio a san allora questa roba
brutto porco ci sentivamo da cinque
giorni e quindi ormai era andata ma si
era andata
devi sentire la presenza ma si era un
bacio la stampa schedati due bacini
bacio a stampo
facevamo sentire la bestia però non è
che ti sei ritratto the anzi quindi non
ho fatto io
infatti se lasciato baciare che per
baciare non ci proveremo in più
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video lo come è stato questo
battesimo su youtube super emozionato a
tratti ha smesso di sudare solo adesso
comunque ringrazio per aver fatto questo
sforzo essere venuto sul mio canale
grazie di essere venuto sembra però un
po grafica alla gente piace anzi no ho
un'idea lo farò anche su instagram ma
iniziate a scrivermi qua sotto quali
possono essere delle idee per dei
prossimi temi di vita buttata che
potrebbero piacervi
se leggete dei commenti di persone che
vi piacciono particolarmente
mettete dei like in modo anche da fare
una scrematura una scrematura esatto
poteva capire cosa vi piace di più cosa
vi piacerebbe che ha detto ciò però
chiudere tutto questo video come si fa
in procura si spegne mai provati prima
chiuderlo